[Musik]
hätten wir leute ist fehlen noch 10.000
abonnenten bis zu 1 millionen jetzt
endlich wurden vollgas wir sind auf der
zielgeraden nochmal abonnieren und jetzt
geht es bei den video bei eine million
kommt es dann in die gruppe die
ortsgruppe welche für porsche cayman ist
bin ich schon ganz mein statement
abgeben ob du geschlagen wirst
denn gestern wegen dem blauen auge naja
ich hab ja sowieso immer ein leichtes
blaues auge
und wenn man dann auch noch als juli
sich denn auch da machen wir mal einen
schönen stil filter darüber dann sieht
das natürlich manchmal sehr
unvorteilhaft aus ja aber das ist
einfach so bei dir weil die kommentare
waren toll doch ich habe nämlich die
filter entwickelt wenn ich schneide
der hat mach das weg und weiß hinter
forderungen mehr bringt dich doch so
juli was man heute etwas knapp und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
klar hätte ich auch natürlich jedes gut
machen heute mal wieder was was es
wirklich in der tat schon länger nicht
mehr gab es herzliche rein
es war ihr wisst es im letztes jahr gab
es ja so auch zu airport videos und ich
habe ende letzten jahres dann auch noch
eins gemacht da habe ich so verkehrt
proteste
die habe ich einfach irgendwo im
internet bestellt und das war ein
wirklich ja man kann eigentlich schon
sagen eins zu eins nach gemacht oder das
kasseler rasinger waren apple logo auf
der verpackung usw und an sich habe ich
auf jeden fall ganz gut abgeschnitten
ich weiß nicht wahrscheinlich haben
viele von euch das video auch gesehen
falls nicht kommt natürlich sehr gerne
immer noch anschauen ich habe letztes
jahr noch airport face bestellt
bayerisch das weiß ich noch und zwar wie
mich das sehr gewundert das war nämlich
auch airport profis und normalerweise
hast die nicht so unter 50 euro bekommen
deswegen mache ich heute jetzt auch hier
dieses video weil ich zeig dir euch mal
kurz und zwar habe ich dieses produkt
gefunden jetzt schon 21 euro und das ist
wirklich der preis den man hier zahlt
also ich will jetzt hier auch möglich
das produkt aus normalerweise geht das
dann meistens auch ein bisschen das dann
plötzlich bei 40 50 euro liegt ich
dachte das wäre so
was irgendwie nicht so also ich habe
dafür wirklich noch 21 euro bezahlt
neues cancelling tws weil es ihr ps
bluetooth blablabla ich gehe mal ganz
kurz hier die bilder durch und man kann
ja eigentlich direkt erkennen es ist
kein airport fake der ersten oder
zweiten generation sondern es handelt
sich hier wirklich um die erfolg proporz
corp da komme ich immer so mit
durcheinander mehr ob der platz dann
sagt er heute
es ist ja kein ipod sind der 21
aufgeklärt
hier stehen noch ein paar daten dazu
also wie sollen wir wirklich noise
cancelling haben haben aber kein keine
smart control also dass deshalb steuern
kann es anscheinend und ein paar
bewertungen bin total begeistert sind
echt super looks good and work travel
und noch ein paar chinesen es gibt es
dort kann ich nicht entziffern
obwohl insgesamt 3,4 von fünf sternen
also ich bin da halt wirklich noch ein
bisschen skeptisch was wir da heute
bekommen haben aber wir packen die jetzt
mal aus und ich habe mir auch noch die
originalen dazu geholt so leute hier
haben wir einer die original
die habe ich auch irgendwann schon mal
getestet oder fazit war da auf jeden
fall echt krass als ich war überrascht
schon zum noise cancelling und sonstigen
sachen die diese dinge alle können der
sound war auch mega man hat eigentlich
gar nichts mehr von der umwelt
wahrgenommen das einzige problem waren
meiner meinung nach weswegen ich die
dann auch glaube ich wieder
zurückgebracht worden
das ist schon so ein zehn monate her der
preis ja 280 euro dafür und da dachte
ich da bleibst du auf jeden fall bei
deiner alten airport hier habe ich mir
jetzt ausgewählt für heute obwohl wir
die eigentlich gar nicht brauchen also
bisher nun zu vergleichen ok dann kann
ich eigentlich auch wieder zu machen
aber das hier ist jetzt das produkt um
das ist heute geht an sich sieht anders
aus oder also 21 euro ich bin mal
gespannt was sie können alter kassier
steht sogar auf deutsch drauf mit
kabellosem lade case das hat mir
oder wo es sind jetzt die kommen von ich
denke mal aus
woher denn sonst okay hier haben wir
jetzt kein apple logo drauf oder so aber
das habe ich auch nicht erwartet
finde ich auch eigentlich nicht gut muss
ich sagen bei den 150 euro standen hier
auf direkt designed by apple in
california
hier steht jetzt nichts aber es ist
ähnlich aufgebaut
und hier haben wir jetzt das produkt
kann man auf denen steht jetzt aber
wieder ganz klein drauf designed by
apple in california ja schon mal ganz
gut aber okay und sogar wieder
aber jetzt habe ich noch eins was wir
meine sammlung tun kann das kabel ich
hatte eigentlich schon so viele
durchfallen die immer wieder jetzt habe
ich gerade mache einzigen können ich
habe einst bei mir im zimmer und eins in
meinem auto das habe ich wieder ein
drittes tier verschwinden alle kaufe ja
ich will jedes einfach ich habe nur noch
ein iphone vertikal das hat mir
vorgenommen und puls weggeschenkt alle
wirklich kein stück na ja ich gebe dir
ein ziemlich ungeniert ja ich weiß es
nicht die verschwinden hier in der
wohnung stinkt irgendwie interessieren
also ich muss sagen für 120 euro gut
dann kam auch noch versand obendrauf
lockt das waren auch nochmals neun euro
aber die verpackung ist schon dafür
schön gemacht und zwar alles sauber oder
ja ich bin jetzt mal gespannt was sie
können also bis jetzt sehe ich noch kein
und hier oben steht was auf chinesisch
drin
siehste das ist jetzt bei den original
natürlich nicht der fall
aber eins weiß ich habe jetzt gerade
einmal die originalen borgward kurz also
die sind auf dem feld schon jetzt bin
ich mal hier gespannt also ich habe
eigentlich gar keinen unterschied
erkannt außer dass die schrift hier
steht das auf chinesisch drauf hat war
es dann auch schon
die connect ich jetzt mal meinste der
sound fehlt weil ich glaube jetzt um
irgendwo irgendwann muss man ja
abstriche machen für 21 euro das wird
sich ja sonst für die gar nicht
rentieren denke ich denke dass dadurch
vielleicht kein bass oder so
weil die sind ja günstiger als die 1000
m s oder so und die waren ja weil ich
hoffe mal der akku reicht da jetzt jeder
dort noch nicht dein airport frohsinn
nicht mit diesem iphone verbunden ja
dann verbindet die mal kommen die heißen
jetzt sogar fast direkt mathe ist halt
noch nicht immer noch nicht doch jetzt
uns wissens kern weggetreten ja heißt
jetzt verbunden
das case hat nur noch als krank
interessiert echt immer gestört hat
kummer das hatten jetzt zwar bei den
fans für 50 euro auch aber die haben wir
jetzt nicht mal die hälfte gekostet wo
führten das noch hin
also als wir damit angefangen haben mit
dieser reihe immer sowas zu testen da
waren welche dabei die waren ganz in
ordnung aber wir hatten noch keine die
dann auch direkt airport schießen und
dann dieses konnten für 20 euro ich bin
jetzt echt mal brutal auf den sound
gespannt was machst du alles gratis
klappt so etwas macht er das macht ok
jetzt konzentriere ich warte mal was
einmal kurz stecken wollte weil wir
haben jetzt hier zum beispiel keine
funktion für dieses neues cancelling
also wir können es jetzt hier nicht
aktivieren das hab ich mir auch gedacht
war bei den 50 euro auch nicht so aber
es stand ja dabei dass sie das haben und
ich weiß dass ich glaube auch bei den
die wir das letzte mal getestet haben
dass die verkäufer das halt einfach dazu
schreiben und für dieses neue scans
liegen dann einfach weil sie so tief ins
ohr gehen meist das ist an deren neues
kennenzulernen weil ich dich jetzt ein
bisschen weniger hören kann oder
generell die umwelt ein bisschen weniger
beiden kann weil er diese tropfen sind
dort ins ohr gehen aber mit einem
aktiven noise cancelling system hat das
natürlich nichts zu tun na ja gut das
habe ich genug gelagert wird checken
meinen sound hast du das cover gaal
guck mal das ist ein auto
also okay jetzt bin ich mal gespannt auf
die playlist
schreckliches league ist am leben ich
habe gleich what we do an
oder liegt es an den dingern ohne scheiß
die gehen so hart laut körperverletzung
aber warte mal ich mach jetzt war ich
glaube ich muss man vielleicht nichts
anblick war gerade demente kraft also
ich hatte noch nie so kofferen borisow
laut gehen ich muss jetzt mal ein
anderes litern was ich kenne also mein
erster eindruck gerade war grausam
naja ich sagen ich weiß ganz genau was
gehört für mich leicht gemacht hast mit
der stufe ich gerade erst bin und es ist
schon so hässlich laut negativ gehen so
lautete da christi dorfladen von also
ich muss sagen was jetzt passiert denn
hoffen feldkirchen der wohl das zeug ja
auch nicht von so großer qualität schild
vor der verschwindet jetzt sollen bei
meinem kopf also ich muss wirklich sagen
vom sound ja ich sage jetzt nichts also
da verstehe ich dann die 20 euro
nur ich frage mich halt alles macht auf
der einen seite natürlich schon sind
sowas zu produzieren weil es bestimmt
viele leute gibt die sich denken war es
20 euro die kaufe ich mir auf jeden fall
weil die sehen ja auf jeden fall aus wie
die originalen aber an sich ist es eine
enttäuschung also meiner meinung nach
herausgeschmissenes geld wenn es einem
nur auf den flex ankommen dann kann man
das vielleicht verstehen aber die kommen
auf keinen fall an die für 50 euro an
und dann die original elf gar nicht du
hast es mit mikrofon ach so genau am
mikrofon das was man noch machen
tschuldigung das hatte ich ganz
vergessen dann rufe ich mal kurz durch
ne yo alter bist du sicher dass du über
die airports drin du bist weil die
qualität des portals also das ist echt
gut
das ist 16 würfe gut dass das letzte was
sie hat johanna huskies alter oder ist
echt gut
vor allem mein handy läuft es halt in
meinem zimmer also die connection war
auch gut wobei das ja auch eigentlich
immer der fall ist warte man also dann
sitzt er jetzt irgendwo ein asiate in
seinem keller und hüfte wahrscheinlich
an diesen dingern für 21 euro
der bürger fühlt so bei denen ein scheiß
und bei denen keines mehr
so hätte der jetzt hier noch was am
sound verbessert das werden die besten
dinge die wir je hatten
aber vielleicht ist das dann das
teuerste teilweise also das hat dann
raus gelassen ich werde so richtig noch
nicht schlauer aus diesen ganzen
produktion aus schönen sind muss ich
sagen wollte ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen abonniert den kanal last nur
noch um da und schreibt vor allem noch
weitere ideen für videos gerne in die
kommentare oder immer mir bei unserem
trikot instagram hat sich alex wie kanal
abonnieren noch 10.000 für eine million
or 1
danke fürs zuschauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]